all right and we are live
the last word with lord cognito
anybody's
friday morning what's going on in there
we got some special
royalty in the bill what's going on we
got royalty coming in the building and
just to flip it up
uh i'm gonna just bring her into this
thing right
now so we're gonna start an introduction
ivantes style so you guys are here for
my uh
inaugural yeah the debut of the
introduction
let's go welcome to the last word
episode
112. i'm extremely excited about our
special guest
so let's get started i'd like to
introduce a lady who brings a positive
energy to everything she does and is
surrounded by an awesome community of
lovelies
a guardian who fell in love with destiny
2 after her first vault of glass raid
and will even serenade her stream while
she sings along with her music
she always has a space in her backpack
to help others experience new activities
and yet can low man any challenge you
throw at her with the best of them
introducing the creator and host
of the zoe twitch channel a titan mane
who knows punching is the only way
and is coming to us all the way from the
united kingdom some many hours ahead of
us but i'm not sure how many
let's welcome zoey to the campfire
welcome zoe
hi making me blush
don't take compliments he's taking me
out of work
that's how you bring them in hey thank
you
how's it going so happy to have you zoey
how you doing it's nice to be here i'm
doing well thank you
yeah nice nice nice good to have you by
the campfire
long overdue so uh what you've been
playing like is it has it been strictly
destiny lately any other things get a
chance to sneak in
um yeah i only stream destiny at like
at all and then off stream we've been
playing a little bit of cars humanity i
don't know if like
that counts as a video game no but
that's definitely entertaining with the
right group
yeah with like me and my mods and then a
few others from child jumping
it's a lot of fun mm-hmm that's what's
up
nice nice nice
you want to jump into some questions for
the lovely guests absolutely
so miss zoe uh just before we get into
destiny a little bit here and i know i
threw a little bit at you in the intro
but i wanted to
let our mods get to our world get to
know you a little bit and uh just kind
of wanted to see like when it comes to
uh gaming itself i know you're playing a
lot of disney and stuff but what
what was like the first game you
remember playing kind of stuck with you
and what have been some like big
favorite games that you've played along
the way before
we know destiny is special for all of us
but we kind of like to know what's uh
what was the path to destiny
um i kind of tried video games
throughout my
i suppose teenage years my grandparents
got me a ps1
so i played tomb raider on that i had
metal gear solid 2 i don't really think
i played that too much though
nice um and then
i played on my brother's xbox sometimes
i played gta on that midtown madness on
that
wow i remember midterm now i loved that
game you could just listen to music and
drive around it was great
yeah it was one of those weirdly like oh
xbox you could have your own playlist
too so you could literally like listen
to your own playlist while playing video
games so i suppose i always was meant to
do something like this
[Laughter]
so yeah i just enjoyed that um
and then i played like other games along
the way i played a little bit of call of
duty black ops
didn't really get into it that much i'd
play like
an hour here or there it wasn't like an
everyday thing
no um
i liked watching other people play story
games i know that sounds weird but i
never really
like got into playing story games myself
but i didn't mind watching other people
play them because it was like watching
the story rather than having to do
something
it's like going to movie theater and
watching last of us for like 40 hours
yeah yeah i get it
um and then yeah i don't really fall in
love with video games and play them
every day until destiny
i don't like i i was a typical
i don't know i don't know if i want to
say that actually um i was a
what a general woman would do in the uk
like
go to work
[Laughter]
a responsible woman yeah like um
watch soaps like tv dramas when i got in
i used to watch them every day like in a
row they'd be like far i watched
and then i found destiny and literally i
haven't watched live tv in like four or
five years now
wow wow so what what made you start like
what
was it first of all who like kind of
brought you to destiny
and then what was the hook that made you
stay
in it well i kind of brought myself to
destiny so
when i um i bought the playstation for
my ex
but like we were together when i bought
it but it was like a pre-order thing
and i broke up with him before it got
delivered so
i got myself a ps4 there you go it came
with destiny
this is awesome
so i played with a group of people and
his cousin actually happened to be part
of our friend group he was a really nice
guy so it didn't bother me or anything i
was happy to hang out with whoever
so occasionally like very super
occasionally like once every so often
when i was still on ps4 he'd
try and play with us and then he just
got so mad one time
when i was trying to teach him how to do
king's fall raider he like literally
got so mad and everybody was like you
don't have to leave bud
like you just couldn't cope with me
knowing what to do and him not knowing
what to do i haven't told him sorry ever
i don't think that was really funny
though
my my d1 friends who i'm still friends
with will remember that
nice wow the next half of you zoe
showing him what to do
in a rain how dare you i see that's just
an insecure man
out there think about it though i didn't
play video games really in
in the entire relationship with that
person like we'd play worms like to like
who did the dishes and stuff that was
about it that's kind of awesome
rope races if you were words oh my god
that's awesome yeah so
yes i didn't play video games at all so
it was probably really weird for him to
and i did i just naturally was seemed to
be good at them and good at leading
raids i joined raids and people didn't
really speak up and it would all be
messy so i'd end up being like right
come on let's do this and that
you took out you took ownership of that
you were in us
you need a leader in a raid if you don't
have a leader it's it falls apart and
sometimes you'll join groups and
nobody just automatically takes that
position and then i kind of
felt like a hat too just to get it done
and that is like how i kind of started
the sherpa thing and then yeah just been
doing that for years now
nice nice so like again like you started
so
again you said obviously you got the ps4
situation which is awesome
got started salute to that story that's
amazing but um
i guess like you know looking over your
history and stuff like that
you're talking about raids a lot you're
talking about you know history so what
was the raid that kind of got you in
so before i made friends with my main
group of friends
um i met a group of dutch people
and only one of them spoke english and
they taught me how to do wall of glass
with i learned links is left in dutch
and
raped right oh man that's kind of
you're right you're rating cross
language barriers that's talent right
there
that's about that was my first ever raid
but it still made me fall in love with
it and then
i made friends with my like main group
of friends shortly after that
i'm not sure how i initially met them
but i was doing
like maybe lfg and we were stuck on
crota for ages and ages
and like different people came in and
out i ended up think i met my group of
friends through doing that
and then i stayed friends with them for
the rest of the time that's awesome
that's awesome yeah so i sell out soon
to the chat they list listening to this
the greatness stories dude a vault of
glasses we just like to hear you
speak so glowingly i gotta ask is vault
of glass your favorite or
just first or both you know what except
uh
it kind of gets my favorite spot just
from the nostalgia and the fact that it
made me fall in love and
with the game and get to where i am now
essentially
um i actually got fourth in the world
football of glass challenge mode too
wow
it makes my mind go black
wrath of the machine's probably my
favorite if you want if it was just
based on no memories
rough of the machine it's
what's yeah i was going to say go with
that first
the bit where you're going along the
bridge i love that part oh
i see ginger i like the boss fight too
yes yeah yes definitely definitely a lot
of fun mechanics
very rewarding raid
oh yes absolutely
absolutely kind of got that back now
yeah yeah yeah we have it's great
i've been really enjoying this new sword
yeah
it's very funny like in chat we've got
crotazen king's fall you just vented vog
and wrath
all d1 raids no d2 mentioned so i'm
actually curious like
so what's your favorite d2 but it seems
like
most people in chat and like with you as
well are putting d1 above d2 what do you
think d2 raids are missing as well just
out of curiosity um
last wish is probably my favorite d2
raid um
and i think i think d1 just gets the
nostalgia factor that ruins it for d2
maybe in like the future will look back
and say because they are amazing raids
and destiny too
yeah so i i don't know how that always
happens but
i think it's nostalgia and we haven't
done them for so long i think a lot of
people would love to go back and like
have a day where they did them all
i was like i would wait until like
spring maybe summer we'll talk about why
some of that might
have date shifted but uh yeah it's like
i'm guessing vault of glass will become
about sometime in the spring we'll see
so everyone will get a chance to
experience it again
in 60 frames absolutely way
it's the most exciting thing for me like
that we're gonna get to do d1 raids on
pc
people a lot of people are like oh we
don't like re-skinned content blah blah
blah i'm like but we've never done this
on pc
ever please i want to yes that is true
it's gonna be gorgeous especially with
like hdr and just like start going full
resolution be like
oh yeah oh yeah that's going to be
glorious
there's no question forte over here in
chat with the
the odd man out i love crown of sorrow
the most by far i don't think i've ever
heard that even in the stuff i've been
doing recently like
working on all the old raids yeah he's
probably just talking about recently i
think
what if i remember i'm going to say he's
a wrath
also guy i know he's not a vault
guy that i know i know he's a rat i
think i'm going to say wrath if i
remember they're my king's fall so i've
got mine there
okay yeah that's a that's a it's a rage
raid it's a rates raid
right it's a big raid big raid big raid
do miss it do you miss it that's what's
up
very cool very cool i wanted to say uh i
was going to ask you to it's like so
a lot of what i'll see you do is like
raid carries and dungeon carries and
explanations and you're helpful
and i kind of wanted to get a little
more on the story about um
the one where you got the help in that
couple for their platinum
um just wanted to get like the full
details of how you set that up like
basically how you ended up almost doing
the whole thing yourself
um just a little detail about that one
well at that point that's kind of what i
was doing to help people
it was like something that not many
people were doing help for just people
off lfg
like ps4 lfg mainly i'd get to i'd help
and this person messaged me asked and i
was like yeah sure
it was a couple and so what i'd do i
wouldn't do it fully solo
so they'd help me at some points so i'd
do the first part i'd go on
my hunter solo going through the
the lamps sometimes it takes me to think
of words that are so easy to think of
um to go through the lamps then i'd get
one of them to run across the bridge
um and one of them to go up top
with me on the bridge part and then
they'd help me do the witch's part
that's just killing stuff
and then at the end they'd just fire
some rockets and i'd saw the boss
it was just it was just the keeping them
safe as much as possible and doing as
much as much of the work as i could
so they'd stay alive nice and get the
flawless
because that was like a lot of people's
last achievement platinum destiny yeah
on ps4 back then so it was just like a
cool thing to help people out absolutely
it's just really memorable for me
because like they were literally
screaming at the end they were so happy
i think that's what made me literally
fall in love with helping people the
reactions you get from something
amazing that's awesome that's awesome
yeah it's like
i always tell people like when you you
do a raid it's literally a bonding
experience
with those people and um you know
whether it be
order the first times you beat it or
just someone who's never beaten it like
you said
that joy that they get right that
they've accomplished it and it is so
cool
it's definitely definitely something
that's hard to replicate what i was
gonna ask you is about the
the low man challenges like this is
something you do
like you you are like a one or two
person
specialist of six man raid
encounters like how did this whole thing
start like what you're doing that like
beating them up
with less than the required six
guardians
um i suppose i just wanted to prove that
i was decent
on decent it sounds like that's beyond
yes just i don't know it's a reason i
stopped using cam and stuff like that
too it's like i just
sometimes i just want people to notice
my gameplay and not just
like that i'm a girl or that i'm nice
and all that that's great but like
like hi i'm actually all right at least
look check me out
that is impressive what was the first
like
little low person rage dude
um well i suppose croto without really
knowing that that's what i was doing
because
i didn't i didn't really know about
lumen challenges in d1
so i was just kind of doing things to
help people i wasn't really
doing it for because it was a low one i
didn't realize to be honest
right but then um i'd seen a lot of
people do
two mans like callus and argos and
then it's pretty easy so i was
playing with family a lot of the time
he's like an insane gamer
and went and just knocked both of those
out first try so that was pretty fun
wow and i just i don't know i've always
part of helping people
do raids is you kind of sometimes have
to do their job for them and i noticed i
was decent at it
like i could do my job on somebody
else's as well so it just kind of goes
from that wanting to be challenged as
well
in gameplay and it just feels good to be
able to do it i suppose
nice so what's been the what's been the
hardest to like
low low person rate
um i say insurrection prime is hardest
just to the point that you have to learn
it like it's the back of your hand
you literally have to learn it so well
that you're not thinking about the
actions that you're taking you just do
them because it's become muscle memory
you know it so well
like you could do it with your eyes
closed that's what you've got to get to
that point to be able to do it
it's it's hard i'd say my favorite was
probably crown because
me and frank too man the whole raid not
just the boss wow i am
so that was fun we literally did that
from start to finish there was
some cool little tricks at the phase one
yeah i was gonna say with the little uh
so i had to we had
you had to get good rng we didn't
flawlessly
put rng on that face so we'd wipe a few
times and when we got the
things to come in the right place you i
jumped up on warlock
put my arms through the wall with chaos
reach to kill the third ogre to open the
third wall to do
what wow that was a pretty cool trick
serious nice nice wow that is
super impressive like i like how she's
so casual about yeah
yeah just you know and then all i did
was all i did was the chaos reached
somebody who's willing to teach you i
don't i think most decent players could
do it if they practiced enough
like i just practiced a lot that is
that's awesome like tremendous
dedication
just like i said just love like you made
a good point
definitely in reference to when you
you're helping people it's like you said
i have a person in my clan who's like
that citizen
where it's like he knows he has an idea
of like who's struggling so then he
starts to
develop that multitasking where you're
able to all do your job and then also
kind of take someone else's job if
they're struggling
so it doesn't make sense based on what
you're saying you keep playing you
practice his muscle memory
and then after a while you get to get
all these mechanics in your head that's
that's still awesome two people right
wow super super impressed
i think it helps with sherpas and with
low man things that my brain
automatically goes to how can i fix this
if something's going wrong
so so just like that natural thought
process kind of
led me into doing these things because
that's what i was kind of doing anyway
that's awesome that's all i got one or a
question for
the ladies over here oh yeah now uh
crucible
um i came across a very um humorous clip
of yours
where um yes some people were not
playing within the rules
you were not happy
to the point where you know actually
went to look at this person's of like
kd and skills and stuff like that and
you saw that how terrible they actually
were
to expose them that they were literally
using hacks and stuff like that
please tell me about like these
experiences do you experience this kind
of stuff a lot in a
pc crucible um not so much in general
crucible i like
i wouldn't say i'm the best pvp player
so i can't always tell if someone's just
good or if they're cheating and i hate
the fact that we're at the point where
if someone's good you assume the feeling
which is kind of bad um but obviously
when you can see stats of somebody who's
like a 0.5 and they're getting like 5kd
for that week there's clearly something
going on
well you can tell that too because you
can just check the amount of games
generally if it's a recurve they'll play
like seven to 14 games max on that on
that account
if you're looking at like a hundred
games in the salon 5k there's something
going on there
i just love the disgust in your voice
when you expose the person
i was down i was like oh she's hilarious
absolutely
i'm very sarcastic so yes yes
she later not really okay yeah i can't
help it
she's like look at this she's like
there's no way
it was classic stuff here glad you got
the chat loud what's up cat daddy what's
going on
yeah final one for me i wanted to ask um
so we've had three dungeons so far and
you've obviously soloed them all
uh what has been your favorite dungeon
so far
um chatterthrone was my favorite solo
wow
um my solo flawless of that was like
really fun
and pretty good because i managed to do
it in 30 minutes
i didn't realize when i started it how
little time there was before down time
before the start of this season
and like it gets to like there's 20
minutes left and i'm
just before the yoga that's like the way
it's down time it's like 20 minutes i'm
like oh crap and i literally just
zoomed through the whole thing it was
crazy damn
wow i'm pretty sure i did it at least
double that when i did mine
so well i did when i did my original i'm
just going to go ahead and probably took
me ages but like
i don't know it just everything went
perfect from the moment somebody told me
that there was only like 20 minutes left
i was like right that's it that we're
doing it right now
nothing to lose basically right yeah
yeah
wow that's super that's awesome if if
you've seen it
i make some dangerous moves just to keep
going like
when i was trying to do the solo
flawless in general i'd slow down and
kill all the ads on the
when you're going you know the travel
part up after the yoga mm-hmm
i just ran past all that crap throwing
myself hearing aids
literally just ran past it all that's
awesome
like i don't care about you he'll go
is legit that's no joke even for just
trying like
even with a group i've seen people take
so much longer that's
yo shout out to alert he said 30 minutes
it takes me that long just to decide
what boots to
equip this game in gear
oh yeah well zoe we are so happy to have
you with us joining us
from over there across the pond and uh
yeah nothing else nothing really major
happened yesterday for the world
adventures
nothing happened yeah nothing nothing
too much to talk about
no in all seriousness though um yeah
they dropped kind of a big bomb
so we got the news and
it's been i think mostly from what i've
seen on twitter received reasonably from
what there's some cynical people but
uh beyond light has been delayed to
november
10th so what is that it's about six
weeks right roughly from what it was
september 22nd to november 10th
so they said little little one from deej
of course he had uh he had to put his
signature on this one as the first
chapter in a new trilogy of expansions
beyond light is the beginning of a new
era of destiny 2.
we have a powerful story to tell and
incredible new features that we are
really excited for players to experience
as always our goal is to make the
coolest most entertaining expansion we
can possibly for our fans
to that end we are doing what's best for
the game and moving the launch date
past few months have been a challenge
and will continue during this pandemic
we've learned to create together in a
new way but having to work apart from
one another
despite these hurdles we're still
committed to the same level of quality
that our fans expect
over the coming weeks we'll be unveiling
more of what we're working on for beyond
light and what also
it means for season of arrivals which
now will extend to november 10th
beyond light sets the stage for an
incredible future in destiny 2
and though it's coming later than we
originally anticipated we're excited to
continue that journey
with you this november so zoe i just
kind of wanted to get your uh
kind of real reactions how you've been
thinking about this one just your
thoughts on it so far
um about the move in the day yep
i don't i don't care at all to be honest
like
there's so there's so much to do right
now then bringing up all the raids
means i've got an insane amount of
people wanting raid helps to do all
those raid
things uh to get all the triumphs and
not only to get all the triumphs
insane amount of people who need anarchy
there's insane amount of people who need
haribo
i'm literally could not be busier right
now i'm
like yeah give me a bit longer thanks
like what my streams are blowing up
constantly sure do more of that
yeah literally it's true though it
literally is it's
true for everybody right now it's insane
yeah it's been crazy
well you seem pretty much on board
cognito
thoughts yeah i saw your tweet yesterday
so i figured i'd just you know crack
open the can of worms and see what was
going to come out of there for you yeah
um look you know
this is just pure selfishness you know
as far as the studio itself
and needing more time all that i'm
always going to be for a delay right i'm
always going to be
pro studio when it comes to a quality
title that's about to come out
and i'm anticipating so look what this
would this have happened under
activision probably not
so this is something last year i
normally delayed but i think with uh
right okay how long was shout out if you
ever remember it was like three week
delay maybe it wasn't like big
yeah maybe half of this i think i think
yeah for me this
great good good sorry do you think if
they were working from home that this
would have happened though
i was just at the studio i was just
about this might not have happened
i was lit i was literally my next point
because i said look at first i was like
dad
so long no fam for dip you know so i was
a little emotional
but then you know when you really look
at it logistically right
you know we're in a pandemic you know
people can't go
in to you know to the officer studio and
i
you know i've heard you know i've had a
lot of developers on
on on ireland's podcast and they have
said you know
that some of the hardest things to do is
like
mocap and and and music with orchestras
things that involve
coming in and you know a congregation of
people
to create so they've got to get creative
right they've got to get creative to try
to get these things done
and um yeah i mean it it's one of those
things you got to be respectful and
understand
i think the old you know what it is i
know what my major disappointment it
really
isn't the fact that it's delayed it's
when it's delayed
because for me as a gamer this is pure
selfishness now i
trust me i understand bungie and i
respect the decision
i'm just talking about for me as a gamer
november's rough
november because like i have like i
think we got like cyberpunk
and and then we got you know valhalla
two new
consoles halo mate possibly you know
probably it's
probably you know we'll baby sort of
it's time everything's getting delayed
never mind that's coming next year
everything
is literally in that window and
the other thing is last uh what you call
it last last word
we did i had took that week off in the
old day of work
now you can un take that week off and
move it oh but i got to see if i could
do it but
come on you got this much time and it's
not a holiday you're still good
there'd be like thank you for just
explaining that you just do this so
easily
my problem yeah thank you i'll just
bring you in to work there you go i'll
take care of your job
i'll take care of my job you make my
videos it works totally fine yeah and
you kick boxes now so
clearly i can take over videos
i'll let you handle the audio and video
editing on my end you got that
just trade rolls for a couple weeks it's
fine sip
cake i'm just joking but all seriousness
you know look
it's we we have to be empathetic to the
situation
you know i i was hoping it was october
but you know i got a deal
we got a deal it's just a lot of stuff
coming out so e
what do you think uh
for me obviously it's like i want them
to make the game that they want to be
proud of putting out
they don't have activision saying hit
this date and it gets
maybe shortened cut whatever it is um
and as you said we're in the middle of a
pandemic this entire country sucks at
handling a pandemic apparently
clearly just gonna say it um
so we don't know the timing of things i
mean the fact that
we're getting any games this year at all
like i just booted up ghost of tsushima
yesterday and
i'm just happy to be able like just the
fact that some games are coming out in
the middle of all this like
movies the movie theater seems like a
notion that i'm not going to be going to
until 2021 and i'm sitting here in july
yeah that's like i know there's supposed
to be movies like top gun
and the next james bond like coming out
over it like in
holiday time frame and i'm kind of going
i don't know maybe
maybe not we'll have to see how things
go if we can get our act together over
here maybe
i'm sure the rest of the world will
figure it out far before us but
so that's all going on bungie's been
working from home since like february
because they were one of the first ones
to shut down as well so i'm like
i totally get it because as you said
orchestra mocap just
walking down the hall asking somebody
something be like well i gotta schedule
this zoom meeting and then talk to them
it's like nothing goes fast anymore
there's no way
so i totally understand that
but yeah i think one of the biggest ones
is as you said in november but it's the
proximity which is yeah we'll see how
long this lasts but it's the proximity
to cyberpunk
because like there's occasionally
there's years where games
last of us cyberpunk red dead redemption
two there's certain ones that people
will like
move away from and when cyberpunk got
moved to like november i was like sweet
i get like a solid six seven weeks with
destiny then i can jump into cyberpunk
and now it's nine days away and i'm like
oh crap
because i really want to play cyberpunk
it looks like a lot of fun oh absolutely
cd projekt red
yeah it looks like really really cool
now granted
that game has just as much chance to be
delayed again
yes just because it's it's so grand in
scope so maybe that one will get delayed
and all my prayers will be answered
but i will actually say that like this
season like i'm looking forward to doing
the raids like working on the solo
dungeon probably help some people with
that not nearly as many as zoe because
she's crushing the help
that's oh yeah she did she's just like
all right next raid just pull your
ticket you go
next next next next next but i will say
like there's been like a couple games
coming out over the summer that i wanted
to play like
ghost just came out verizon zero dawn
comes out uh
august 7th i still haven't played final
fantasy 7 remake
and death stranding just came out as
well like there's four pretty big games
and i'm like
i just got more time to play him too so
but honestly for me i was like outside
of cyberpunk being that one caveat that
it's close to and it's just so big
that's what i worry about huge and i'm
listen i i like halo oh and
yeah you know listen nothing's gonna
stop me from playing this
but that's tough with those three
i'm just hoping that the other two
somebody blinks please move your release
date
so i could actually have a life i think
halo is going to be very tied to xbox
and i i can't imagine the amount of
pressure
that 343 has on them right now being
like yeah
yeah you are coming with the console
hell or high water yeah
halo's coming with that console i think
but i could honestly see
cyber cyber january february like
take that that winter spot just because
not for them to move because when they
come out people are going to play it but
honestly just
i could imagine their development still
taking a little longer than they think
as big as that game is
true and i i really hope so the only
issue they have is they have now delayed
that game
twice so to delay it a
third time that listen
marketing wise that's a tough one
because they just told their base look
we need more polish we need this
and this is that would be number three
number three
delays yeah i i mean if that and again
maybe it won't happen
but i mean you have assassin's creed
valhalla
halo consoles destiny cyberpunk in the
same month
watchdogs legion is within 30 days of
all of this like it's
there's a lot so it's just it to let
destiny have its time to shine
and not nine days from cyberpunk it's
just me being a little hopeful because i
want destiny to have its time to breathe
that's the thing that's the big thing i
want and and that's the part that her
because it was like
man you know if it if it was any like
even if there was any way it could come
like october at least you got that
little
window to mess around with but it's like
yeah it's a tough one it's always not
phased she's like
i'm just looking at this she's just
she's looking literally i'm just sat
here thinking i'm just going to play
destiny
she's a destiny fan and she's like i got
people to carry through raids for the
next like
three months i was like i got a full
schedule i'm good we either way
she's like cyberpunk punk she was like i
feel like if it looks good and i see
other people playing it i might play it
in my spare time but i'll still be
playing destiny every single day so
dedication i respect it i respect it
it's gonna it's gonna be november two
consoles e
oh i know bruh
this is gonna get spooky very well i got
a pc
so i'm good on the microsoft stuff
and then honestly five
pieces of five i gotta wait and see i
don't know
i don't know if i'm gonna jump on either
at the start what's
this e is not getting their ps5
at launch i mean i'd like to part of
playstation
can i roll my eyes any harder in the
back of my head
what is this is a development zone we
have to break this down
really do tell worlds depend on
like timing and pricing and stuff like
that just the way things are going
and if there's the like honestly it just
kind of depends
what's coming at first and how busy we
are with like beyond light basically
interesting interesting well it's not
going to be an xbox so it's going to be
a playstation at some point
well you're getting microsoft okay
you're just buying right playing the
game
system but lord sony himself
i mean i would like to honestly i just
got to see
i really actually want to but i just got
to see how it goes
sadly i know i'll probably get the one
with the disc too yeah so
this is mr nvme this is this is this is
him this is
good fine i'll get it just just to shut
you up
tell everyone i'm still waiting for
those days be like all right fine i'm
just gonna send you like my phone
pre-order be like here you happy
now honestly i'm extremely excited about
the console to see what it will do
like miles morales was awesome like
horizon zero dawn forbidden west looks
gorgeous so i really can't wait for that
one the other side of it though i'm very
curious about like nvidia's new graphics
cards like if there's a 38v ti that
meant
like dropped sometime in like september
october that might take place in the
bushes
wow
okay okay i'm learning i'm i'm
i'm gonna be playing some playstation
games i just got to see exactly
what this is at launch for e we heard it
here first at the last word
i'll clip that one i'll just chuck it
it's all good
but now look it is what it is you know
obviously the news came out
you know they got ahead of it bracing us
for it now
and you just want them to make you know
you want them to make the best version
of destiny
they can make so you know kudos you know
to them
to have that you know working under
these new conditions this is the new
normal y'all like
i really do feel that like a lot of
studios are gonna be
in this predicament from this point on
we still don't have any
particular light at the end of the
tunnel just yet with the whole pandemic
in this country
at least yeah this country yeah you know
so studios are going to have to adjust
and it's tough video game the the
process of creating video games really
involves collaboration
and coming together and work from home
you you've got to get creative so salute
to them and hopefully like i said they
uh
reached that that time that time frame
so
we also got news in twab which dropped
like much earlier in the day than ever
before
we got news about the calendar getting a
bit of an update
yes so not a ton per se
but we've got now we know season of
arrivals goes through november
10th um zoe's going to be running people
through raids till november 10th
and then she's going to go knock out
deep zone crypt and then get back to
running people's
raids but i wanted to ask you guys what
you thought because
we've had the exodus missions we know
there's another side of that with
evacuation
sorry spoilers um we have salsas of
heroes which the dates actually haven't
changed for kind of surprised a little
bit about that
and then we also now we've got festival
lost in here
so i'm going to go through piece by
piece so we've got evacuation
as the other half of exodus i wanted to
see when you guys think
that's going to happen because that
still feels like what would be kind of
the culmination
ending of the season but now that's so
much farther away
do you still see that as being like an
end of a season quest
piece where that you know that exotic
still gonna be right towards the end of
the season and say like
late october or do you think they'll
drop it sooner and just kind of
deal with the delay differently
um if it's supposed to be for the end of
season they'll probably leave it till
the end of season
what do you think like this this
is a weird scenario bro i'm like i'm
messed up
because the delay i guess this is the
first the first time like
this season's rivals now has just got
this
tremendous extension now oh yeah it's
the longest it was already a long season
now it's the longest season ever
yeah like 21 weeks or something yeah so
now it's just like this is a very unique
situation
for this length of time for a season so
now it's just like i want to know like
you know what is
this the thing that i'm i'm very i'm
going to say concerned but
i want to know how to handle the way
seasons have been so far
has literally been this kind of almost
like a time gate you know this happens
this happened and then everything is
supposed to systematically lead into the
next
like you now have to shuffle you now
have to add things to to buffer and
i got to see how they're going to do it
man it's just it's one of those things
that you know
selfishly remember we started off
talking about how
amazing this season was right
season of arrival was amazing and i know
they had
you know everything lined up but now two
months
you've got to put in to i i don't envy
them like this
that's a tough thing two months so yeah
you know i will say this it's not going
to be popular
looking at that calendar
the end i mean they did they said
they're going to be some secret stuff
but
you know festive the loss don't warm my
heart that way
no i said that in my video yesterday i
was like you better temper your
expectations for that one
festival of the lost does not get the
blood pumping for me
so i'm just like again i'm being you
know understanding like
it's probably all they can do some we'll
read about it you know i
manage other things they could do but
it's like what really could you
do to stretch this for two months
what you thinking uh for
me my curiosity for the end of the
season
so we have four planets the way we
handled exodus first was
all four in the same day you're like
okay here's this go do a strike go do
these things go to your
weeklies cool go to mars go to mercury
go to io like you knocked out all four
in a day do they start doing one a week
on the exodus mission
like towards the end of the season
during festival lost hey here's first
planet evacuation pack up all your stuff
get out of here do what you're gonna do
okay next next week go do the same thing
um
but the other thing i'm looking at here
on the calendar is like the interference
mission
we get our one piece of lore per week
and it was like 14 and there was like 15
weeks so it was like
how was it all gonna come now is there
like six weeks of dead dead air type
is it six weeks of reruns in your
favorite tv show before we get to the
new season like
i mean well you do speak to her right
you get the old ones if you can yeah you
can go
back to all of them but if we get all 15
i will say people are gonna have some
zoe what is your season pass out right
now i'm curious as much as you play
uh i don't know over a hundred
yeah i was gonna say that as much as
some people play especially with six
more weeks this could be some of the
highest season passes we've probably
ever seen i can bet you that
people will be like i'm 1100 and be like
yeah i'm it's like i'm 11 20. keep
coming
yeah i mean you know again i
don't envy them to be in this kind of
position
you know it's got to be tough as a
studio to try to endure that you know
and
you know we'll get into it when you know
really like they've got some things that
they want to
talk about but the only thing i can
think of if they they've
got to literally time
gate stuff that was supposed to happen
you know
at a later time so maybe in your case
with those weekly missions we get
we don't get the interferences
consecutively
and those like maybe get split and then
stretch towards the end
basically this is where i'm at with you
it's sad
because we were kind of building this
thing
the arrivals versus opulence thing this
was a nice
little like this this thing was on par
and it's not over but this day was on
par to be the best
individual season i felt of destiny
since seasons were created
right with the prior champion being
opulence
how it's a jeopardy man it's a gemini
okay
okay here's the thing why is it in
jeopardy is the content itself going to
change
yes no because it's going to it's not
going to be delivered in the way
necessary the content is not going to
change the timing of said content will
change there's a difference
so like no i'm saying so this is the
point where you're like
if you take this season on a normal
timeline
if they didn't have the delay
that's one of those things like you got
to give them like a grain of salt when
it comes to some of this stuff for
pandemic development new expansion delay
so it's like
when you go later on opulence is number
one
because this thing had this delay and it
just felt too long in the tooth like is
that what you're
are you worried about these like last
six weeks just like dragging your feet
across the finish line
not like not getting the big climax
you're going for yeah because again if
they had this thing again this is my
opinion looking outside and they could
prove me wrong
and knock this thing out the part with
the
newest adjustments my biggest fear
is the way seasons are set
every week of the season generally
there's a theme that's a progression
towards the end game of transitioning
into to the next
so when you tell someone yo two months
it's not two weeks two months
right we know damn well we're going to
get a few iron banners
right we already see festival of the car
i mean the loss
did right i mean look it is what it is
now
again based on prior experience these
tend to be
filler when seasons were bad these tend
to be
filler kind of content to stretch out
right
based on the contact and the
interference missions
which seem to be you know set up i would
assume again i'm assuming
that things got to be stopped and
stretched and
if that's the case the quality in my
opinion has to go down
on some level i would love to be wrong
and i could be proven wrong
but i think now part of me feels
that that it gets taken out of the
discussion of best
based on these unfortunate events that's
just where i'm that's just where my
mindset is right now
you're gonna it's gonna leave a bad
taste in your mouth because they had to
delay a future season so
if this content was in its normal timing
you won't be able to like
take it out because we're like yeah i
sat here for like six weeks waiting on
the next one i was bored
it's not their fault i'm not mad like
i'm it's just
it just it's just the competitive
like the way this thing was building i
was like man this is on point to be the
greatest season
of destiny in seasons format not
expansion
right that's all it was just a fun
little
game we were doing in competition you
know what i'm saying
that's all i was saying you know saying
but as far as you know so far it's still
it's still good
i mean shout out to hampton optilis is
gonna be better this season because
of just having a raid that's not
including menagerie i i disagree man i i
think
you know look crown is crowned not
taking nothing prophecy is prophecy
i just thought it was going to be a nice
ribbon you know
honestly more than crown
i would put that dungeon over crown is a
crook crown isn't that
bad but that's just like prophecy itself
has a dungeon it's more
i've been bashing my head against it not
as good as zoey
go ahead and throw that out there she's
she's awesome she's done in 30 minutes
um but like even that just the
experience the mechanics
a little frustration on some of the
mechanics but just overall yeah
i enjoy i think prophecy is a more
unique experience and
personally a lot more fun i don't know
i'm biased on dungeons because i love
the things but i think i like it better
than probably
i'm i'm actually with you and to be
that's
to hear me say let's answer it
as far as zoe because you you've done um
crown i'm assuming
a bunch of times right how many times
have you solo the crown let's let's put
your stats up
i've never i've never soloed crown
so we're actually curious like where do
you rank i think this is where you're
going
where do you where do you rank like the
seasons especially like because some of
the top ones are opulence this one's
been pretty
good were these near the bottom of the
barrel for some people where you rank in
this season kind of the ranking of
seasons
even with the delay potentially now
where do you see this one stacking up
i don't know it's all right i'm
definitely not bored this season i
definitely don't feel like i've run out
of things to do
so it's reasonably high up there
what's your obvious obviously i prefer
seasons where we get raids
so is something so what is your outside
of the big expansions because those
obviously take the cake for a lot of
people
what is is opulence potentially your
favorite season
or like forges or where's your where's
your top if you had to rank one
um i like the gambit season
real expansion that is new i won a
gambit tournament
so that was fun for me it was like it
wasn't even just that we got to all hang
out in real life and they're actually my
good friends who i was playing with and
we all went out on nights out and stuff
after
it was hella fun for me that season so
is that the one where like
i'm trying to remember if that was
gambit or not i remember like fall out
and buy shout casting something over
there that he flew over there for
yeah that's that's the thing i won that
was it yeah
that's awesome i remember once it was
like a real life tournament so we went
to like
little places where they had loads of
pcs
in front of people watching that's
really really cool i remember that as
well i remember like
paula was like hey do you need a
shoutcaster he's over there in a suit
him and bye for shout casting
that's really awesome and you guys got
to hang out afterwards
yeah i told him i was going to win
before and then after hour
oh that's fantastic we didn't we didn't
lose the game the whole tournament so i
kind of made it unfair because this was
a lot of people
from the uk who maybe don't know life
destiny like i do
i got benji who's the best world's best
invader yep like
i know who's decent mo who's decent and
then i also got frank
out of redeemer
[Laughter]
so we literally like went in private
gambit games and
thought of boss killing strats the best
way and at literally everything we had
super strats for doing it so i don't
feel like any other team had a chance it
was kind of like
cake walk man should we have just like
when you showed up just like just mail
the trophy
like hey how does this go well there
were there was some young lads there and
they were all rather
rather cocky about how they were going
to win so it was nice to just sit there
smiling thinking oh sure
so i got so i i don't want to mean this
in a bad way but
being a girl in gaming and kicking the
crap out of guys a lot showing like your
prowse and stuff um
that's gotta feel good right well i
don't i don't flex really
in general but if i go do lfg raids and
some guy's heart starts talking to me
like [ __ ] i'm like yo [ __ ] look at my
raid report
has anybody really been like to a point
be like hey i know what i'm doing
um no i'm running have you ever really
had to like check somebody that
like have everybody has anybody like
discounted your ability where you really
got to pull up the receipts on them
i've literally been streaming raid helps
and had guys try and take over the raids
i
literally i'm just like excuse me um hi
you know like where you came in my
stream and asked me to come like raider
i didn't ask you to come help me that's
what i'm here doing hi
they just go quiet then for the rest of
the raid i'm sure
as damn damn sorry with the
strong flex i was gonna say i'm sorry to
all the ladies out there there's a lot
of
i'm gonna just say it because i think
we're far enough in there's a lot of
dumbass guys out there so i apologize
for all of the idiots out there because
ladies you are fantastic for putting up
with
so much in the world um but yeah sorry
there's even still dumb gamer guys
because you'll still beat the crap out
of him they're like i can do it and
you're like i can do it
with one hand tied behind my back and an
eye patch
i actually like staying quiet so
recently i've been doing a few lfg
gardens and i won't like say
i'm good or anything i'll just join the
raid the last for like 30 raid clears
and stuff like that
so i'll join and i won't say anything
i'll just play but i'll quietly be
trying the hardest i [ __ ] can't do
everything that's so cool i like go do
eyes and i can solo them and people
don't expect it so they'll run along
with me i won't give the call out go
boom boom boom
and i'm like and you could just hear
them go
eh
that's that's fantastic um yeah those
are the clips you need to post out there
and be like
hold on let me walk in with my how many
do you know how many total raids you've
done
like all together for d2 um i'm in the
top 1000 for raid clears
um i can tell you how many let me have a
look oh i was like i'm sure
actually i was super close to 500 but
then
over the last like not this season
obviously they're gonna go back up again
yeah but over the last few seasons i
haven't been doing that many raid helps
because there just wasn't people wanting
it that much
so we'd only be doing like three four
five clears a week max
so um i'm down to i'm 997th in the world
so still top thousand
but it's 833 full raids
damn wow super impressive
you said that i'm going to climb back up
now i'm now we're doing this again
because i'll be doing a lot every day
not enough i got to get more not enough
for eight since you gotta get a stats up
yes
so what is your what is your end game
goal say at the end of light fall in
like 2023
do you want seven seven seven seven
raids and then ask bungie for that
plaque
oh no okay i want to go over a thousand
i think i had about
660 something in d1 so i've already been
uh
oh damn um so i don't know just go for
over a thousand now i suppose
well you're not that far away it sounds
like you'll have that probably
now since all you'll be doing is raid
carriers for like the next level
a month yeah yeah that's amazing super
impressive
salute ladies zoey out here killing it
killing it yeah the only thing with them
so it won't make my number go up
when i'm doing anarchy helps and stuff
because we just checkpoint that and it
doesn't count towards full raid
clearance
right right yeah well it's honestly nice
like so i will say how
this like precedent that they set with
the quote featured
raids i know there's like five of them
and most of them are going away
but even then when you have like last
wish
we'll have garden of salvation and we'll
now have deep stone crypt going in the
future
even with the old raids as we keep going
in years and stuff like that they'll
vault stuff
do you like the idea of them
occasionally taking say garden making it
also like a featured raid
and make it either you know unlimited
drops and stuff like that so more people
run it would you like to see them do the
stuff in the future
even though there's a lot going to be
vaulted or how would you like to see
them handle this stuff going forward
i don't mind seeing if they do like
featured raids and
maybe even make like hard modes or
something that they bring out
that'd be cool that'd be cool should i
be cool
sure what about you cog you want to see
them uh feature these things oh well
actually i forgot vault's going to be in
that mix too come
mm-hmm i don't know nine months from now
ish that was the other thing that was
there's a
yeah that was what i was looking forward
to i had it all lined up
it was it was september it was it was oh
vault's not in september vault's gonna
be like six months after launch just put
that in your head
i know it's just you know it's just like
you know it's one of those things where
i got to get over the pouting stage i'm
still a little bit of poutine just yeah
indeed yeah just start all right
eight-year-old go sit in your corner
pout it out now you're gonna stop this
eight-year-old dog
listen
that's right i was just like damn you
know what the worst thing is a gameless
when you're a gamer
the worst thing you can do is finish
this sentence all
year right hey shut up
and everything you know what i hate is
they force
that bungie i'm just talking about
gaming publishers right
that they have this tendency to put all
the
biggest releases in like one month
and everything just cannibalizes each
other so that's
the beauty the beauty of destiny was
always ahead of that
you know what i'm saying so it's just
like damn everything kind of you know
falls in
into that whole journey so it's just
like you know it it just it just sucks
because you want to play these other
games and give everything the proper
attention that it deserves because these
they've worked so hard to bring these
games out so
unfortunately what happens is this is
the reason why i'm sad
when you look at history like they look
at a game like
titanfall 2. oh no it got rid of these
are examples
of games that see it's not about me just
pouting just about
sometimes games don't sell well because
they're too boxed up
next to all these other hitters and
people make tough decisions
so the thing for me is like i don't ever
want it to be a situation now
we got two new consoles coming out right
and people go
well you know i can just wait see we're
hardcore we're destined we're going to
play
but that's not the everyday gamer the
everyday game and say hey i'm getting
the playstation 5.
i got to save my money for that i got to
get a xbox series x
or hey halo's out or they're standing
over that's the thing
you know so i just hope
my hope is that bungie doesn't get
affected
financially by people making tough
decisions but to not pick it up
that's my only thing because yo you let
me tell you cd projekt red is not
a game cyberpunk is out there that's a
huge
release people may make tough decisions
that are not
destiny and i i just i just worry i just
worry this is winter's coming man
winter is coming this is this is tough
wait are we in game of thrones i'm sorry
i'm confused
yeah it's the game of thrones which game
is going to survive
the winter i'm so nervous destiny's
going to survive period
it always does no not that this is a
unique situation bro
we have to admit destiny's been going
for has a
hard how hardcore are you for destiny
man
you and everybody else who's playing
right now and everybody's getting hooked
on rating because zoe's taking them all
through it
so zoe's gotten everybody hooked on
raids raids are fantastic more people
are going to play
i'm like as yes there are going to be
other things that pull people here there
and they may
get back into destiny a little later or
jump in
go try something and come back what like
scenario
let me give you a scenario let's just
say
playstation i know you're right now i'm
waiting to see on playstation 5.
we can admit playstation 5 is yeah it
might be convinced but we'll see
maybe convince convincing all right
we're not gonna act like
miles morales the spider-man franchise
wasn't the most
popular selling thing on playstation
it's up there yeah it's definitely up
there miles morales now comes out
most likely around launch window with
the playstation 5.
it was like right okay you got that
who knows whatever playstation 5
exclusive these are brand new games
um right that people are excited for a
console
then you have the series x right
people have waited you know four or five
years or whatever it is for
from him yeah i know oh is that a shot
across
ps4 is firing on all freaking cylinders
right now i'll tell you that oh
absolutely absolutely
anyway i just got to mess with you
because you know king's
who knows what they're gonna launch
again these are new
shiny games people have
seen destiny to some extent destiny
doesn't have i'm just talking about the
casual
the hardcore we're in one question hey
zoe are you going to play anything else
this fall
um probably not a baited question
and no disrespect to lady zoe come on i
have actually had two friends
like come back in the last week alone
who were old destiny players wanting to
come back and level ready for next
season
see it's like i think honest like i mean
granted yeah the season may be a little
long in the tooth just because time it
got a little screwed up
but i think the way season of arrivals
is going building the narrative the
pyramid ships the planets are leaving
vault of glass nostalgia you know is
going to pull people that's going to be
later but that's another ace in the hole
that they've got
they've got darkness subclasses they've
got a lot of things coming
and we don't even know everything about
it yet i'm gonna definitely
potentially know i sw well hopefully
next week we know more about halo
finally but i was like
there are gonna be games and i'm not
arguing that cyberpunk's probably gonna
pull at people's time
halo assassin's creed valhalla all these
other ones still they've come out year
after year after year all these big
games
come out year after year red dead
redemption 2 last of us there are still
giant games that have ever launched at
the same month
as debt come on yeah chad y'all got to
stop now i understand this is a destiny
podcast
but we got to stop with the capping now
all right these are
blockbuster games and two consoles and
we acted like
oh it's nothing that's these completely
fine
that's gonna be one of those ones people
are gonna get anyway because they take
what they've got
and it's something they can jump into on
their console already they're gonna be
able to play it as it is
okay i'm not saying it's i'm not saying
it's optimal i will never say that okay
this is a happy
situation i haven't said something
destiny has survived through every
destiny killer
and everything else so i still think
that's this is not the same this is
not the same and this is why we're
talking four or
five games we're not talking one
singular
division one singular anthem
we're not talking that this is a unique
situation man this is
this is critical you got to pay
attention to this man trust me what i
tell you it's not that
destiny's not going to sell at all of
course it is all i'm just saying is that
we have to be cognizant that these
games bring crowds that
were not going to buy destiny anyway you
know what i'm saying and these
these are time sync type games that are
quality
cd projekt red cyberpunk assassin's
creed valhalla
like these are huge games with consoles
we got to see that's all i'm saying
we just gotta see i don't think it's
this slam dunk that we're used to
we're used to going up against one game
that's supposed to be in new in the
genre
and we're like yeah we'll see you when
it comes out and then you know we're
cocky
this is different i'm just saying oh all
i'm saying is destiny has survived a lot
it's still the one that's holding strong
with all the stuff that it's faced
so while there may be some bumps with
the november release that's probably
what they had to pick
and i still think in the long run you
may play through cyberpunk
but then you will still come back to
destiny of course
because they want to jump back in zoe's
raid streams
because by that point she will have two
man deep stone crypt
she will have taken out the new dungeon
multiple times and now she's going to
say all right my backpack has got four
spaces
hop it i actually hope the new raid is
really hard to learn on i want everybody
to have to do their jobs
[Laughter]
that's actually a question though
because like when you think of stuff a
lot of d1 raids i think people hold in
high regard
because you had relic runners in vogue
you had the sword and crota
and there's a lot more feeling in say
destiny 2 where
kind of more people have to be on their
game per se i mean granted you're two
manning it but the average group doesn't
have
like the hero sword user and the helpers
like a lot of people are still using
more jobs do you do you like the crota
you know one hero person or do you like
more of the field now where there's more
split jobs granted you're doing
you're far above average but for for
most of us casuals
who even still try and raid it does feel
like more of a split rule like if one
person drops it gets to be a big issue
pretty quickly
um i i'd prefer to teach people what to
do than drag them through so
okay they've got their own job and i can
teach them that specific job that's more
fun for me
and i feel like they can go on to do
that job again after they've left the
raid that they did with me that's even
better
i like that it's a good one
what's the hardest raid for you to teach
somebody
spire
i almost cut against that one breach
and it's really glitchy at the end as
well so sometimes even when you do it
right it doesn't work like you throw in
the balls at the doors and it doesn't
whatever it's called when it arms that's
the word i was thinking
it doesn't arm it and you're like oh my
gosh and like if you've got an
experienced team sometimes you can fix
that if you just
do it fast enough but when you're trying
to do teaching it's just like
the game's against you and you're trying
to help other people it's hard
so zoe got me my clear oh nice yeah
nice i was like hey by the way and she's
like ah come in i was like we got a spot
and like what was it two runs it was
done like we got lucky you said it was
pretty unglitchy on our run
yeah yeah we had a easy run thankfully
yeah i'm pretty sure i botched one of
their like all right throw the ball at
the hand and i threw it not the right
hand i was like oh
sorry everybody that was totally my
fault i screwed up the first one it
would have been one run if i wasn't
holding a ball so i screwed it up
i'll take the blame second round though
i threw it at the right hand
nice figured it
but um sorry back to where we were
we have tangents on this podcast if you
can't tell zoe so when i said it
sometimes gets to be a little long we we
do
i still get nervous throwing that ball
sometimes by the way
okay good at least you typically know
where you're supposed to throw it i
wasn't even throwing in the right place
yours may be like oh i kind of missed my
actual target i'm over here throwing at
the wall and the targets over here so
but when we look at the calendar
obviously we got more time parades so
there's a lot of people that have
moments of triumph is all the way
through november 10th
so there's a lot more time raid carriers
are going to be happening a lot your
triumphs your seals you got plenty of
time for those
i wanted to ask you guys if you expected
solstice of heroes to be extended
or because it didn't change it's still
august 11th to september 8th
i don't know if we're going back to the
az but it looks like we got some pretty
legit literally fire armor
do you guys think this should have been
extended or do you feel
like it is what it is then it's just
staying there
uh what do you think zoe you think it's
uh that one was set in place for
solstice
who knows they might even still extend
it they've been known to extend stuff
while it's already going like they've
done this while it's already happening
so we'll just see what happens
i'm not really a big fan of like the the
mundane task events like festival and
stuff then they're not really
what i enjoy doing yeah like all right
if you've got a good group of friends
and you're having a chat and a laugh
while you're doing them but
like most of those tasks are so boring
what i enjoy about destiny
i'm glad you said that which was my
whole point that some people weren't
understanding in reference to
having to force extend a season when you
have yeah
fix your face you
[Laughter]
so that's what happens you have to
extend and put content like this
that you know it's mundane that you kind
of got to do it it just sucks because
they're in that
position you know based on you know the
world events you know kind of thing and
like i say you just hope
people stick around i actually don't
mind dry times though sometimes because
that's when i start doing things like
challenges
like towards the end of the last season
there wasn't that much to do that's how
i ended up getting a 30-minute fight and
thank you yeah but no disrespect to
ladies and gentlemen she's amazing and
she's hardcore
but the rest of the world when destiny's
not good
plays other games and that's what no
one's
understanding in the chat chat because
the chat's coming for me
is that people go play other things
if you ever read a post that's not
within the destiny community about
destiny like a different like like a
games company's post or something
people hate destiny who are not in this
community
it's like there's so many people that
don't but the ones who do are hardcore
so i think like for what player base we
have now
one thing i am hoping hope hoping
hopefully
words are fun when it comes to the fall
i say fall now it's not quite winter but
it's closer
the new light experience they said
they're looking to
change and kind of revamp that
cosmodrome's coming back in
beyond light specifically for new light
players mostly is where that's going to
be for like you might be able to go
experience the first mission
but cosmodrome is not going to be like
fully fleshed out until season
13 they said uh i'm hoping actually
that's one of those things that helps
people who are like well
i can't buy this right now but hey
destiny's free over here
and if they can make that experience a
little more inviting to some people
those are ones that might stick with a
little more and get some new people
because i've heard
i mean we've talked to enough people
jarv as well it was just like new
light's rough
new light is just chaos yeah yeah
no i agree they've they they've
intimated that they are
making some changes to it to try to you
know make it a little bit more inviting
for for new players and yeah they've got
that that's going to be key for them
coming into marketing you know with the
whole um
you know beyond light season so yeah
it's gonna be interesting to see how
they they adjust to
to get to onboard people right on board
people who haven't
played in a while and to jump in so i'm
curious
are you ready to adorn your mask though
and run into the haunted forest once
again
i'll ask them i was like i know you just
said it but it's like
i was like do you think we're going back
in the so i guess what do you expect for
festival of loss that's a better
question do you expect it to be
masks and i can't remember it was candy
or not but like masks in the haunted
forest or do you expect anything else
um i expect my mods will probably make
me do it sometimes
other than that i won't do it you sound
so thrilled
you're like i could be writing right now
god
i don't know it's just not that
enjoyable to me like going to like 20
vendors to collect this off that one and
then this off that one and then do
something and take it to this other one
i'm like
lots of flying around thanks yeah well
at least you're on pc the flying around
is quicker console people are like i'm
done yeah
new consoles though the flying's gonna
be nice and quick what did you do
what did you do today on gaming oh i
flew around a lot passing this thing to
that person and then back to that person
i did a bounty where i had to kill 10
ads
were you playing ups simulator
or death or death stranding that's
training yeah
i mean yeah i i i completely relate to
it which i always talk about
and um you know it's just again it i've
always looked at it as
a filler event yeah it's never been
historically in destiny's history it's
never been one of my favorites we've got
mummified rewards though
mummified rewards
[Laughter]
like ornaments and stuff maybe that made
me want to put those things on my gun
i'd be more incented to do it
but like so like but then they usually
put them on for brightness too so and i
got craploads of that so i'm just like
buy it don't have to do anything i
always try and
hover around like 50k bright dust i'm
like always scared to spend too much
yeah i'm about there and i'm like i want
to get two i get down like i buy
something for like 3k and it's like an
emote or a ship and i'm down to like 47
i'm like
gotta do all my gotta do these
repeatable bounties i gotta get back up
there
yeah out of control so much stuff comes
through for bright dust i haven't spent
much on silver
sorry bungie love your game just don't
buy that much silver because i haven't
had to
most things eventually i see i can come
back around
i don't buy like every every eververse
set for every character every time i
don't do that
and the nice thing is now it's in the
dungeon so you can just call earn it
which is even better
absolutely i only use brightness
sometimes if something cool comes out
that
chat really wants me to have they'll
send me silver because you can do that
on steam
yeah i've had some things with silver
but the community
dust the community of lovelies they're
helping you out
uh but yeah honestly for me i'm with you
guys festival lost is
i have very low expectations for it
because in the first place
it's just it's going to be the halloween
event and right now during that window
they're doing nothing but beyond light
stuff yeah they're going to be like
okay haunted forest here's a couple
candy bars here's
uh the auto rifle that looks like it
glows again
here you go we're working on this and
honestly i'm okay with that because
yeah it's a little extra something to do
but beyond light's the big one beyond
light is their
major they have to nail that yeah it's
their major moment i mean we've
had our issues with like um weaponry
issues that we've talked about
we've got like everything you know four
planets are going away we're losing the
five raids that people are working on
we're you we're
the games they're going through some big
changes we get new subclasses we get a
new planet but there's some big changes
so
i want that to be nailed so yeah
festival lost i'm like yeah it's just
going to be halloween
fine just let me play something else
then probably
i did want to ask you guys though we
know some activities are
they're going to have increased valor
they're going to have infamy they're
going to be some iron banner events
between september and november
but they have one other thing that says
increased redacted i wondered what you
guys thought
that could be um
any ideas so you can see if you got any
ideas on this one first
um i don't really know
um i gotta guess i'm gonna say
i was thinking trials
well like tokens or rewards or something
or something i mean because it's like
what other real event
is there if it's redacted i mean well
they could have said trial
i mean you could be like increased i was
wondering like somebody i think in my
chat said like
increased exotic drop rate or
increased material farming or something
along those lines i guess maybe
i mean i don't have a ton of ideas
either yeah it's just interesting that
they
they chose to redact that as if you know
it's special yeah special spoiling
something
you know yeah i'm very interested
because valor makes sense obviously
infamy makes sense
you know i the vibe i was thinking was
you know another
recently added pinnacle activity
the only thing i can think well
valerie's crucible but like increased
trials token drops or
yeah i was i was in that role i mean
that was like the other one it's like
they're like
nightfall stuff which they're going to
have grand master coming up anywhere
which starts next week
um so you're going to have longer to
work on conquer which i will say that's
one
positive thing since we get like six
more weeks i wonder how they do
the grand master nightfalls because
before it was yeah
six or seven weeks or something in the
last couple weeks you could pick all of
them to like work through if you wanted
to try and go for the title you're gonna
have so long to up that season pass like
to get up to 1080 or whatever
or however high you need to get like
grand master
and conquer hopefully is more attainable
for a lot of people this season because
they have more time to go for it
right actually justin made a good point
which is i'm leaning in his way which is
he said it may have something to do with
things towards the end of the season
because you don't redact something
unless you want to spoil it
so clearly something towards the end of
the season that was planned
that they don't want to tell us that
maybe
like put it this way um remember how
like when we did season of dawn
right and towards the end the imperium
foundation came out and then we had the
fractal line
so you can't say season of frac you know
increase fractal line
at the beginning of the joint because
then you spoil you know what's that
about kind of thing so
yeah it's possibly you know some build
up activity
maybe not a community event could fill
that space like this that's true
that's why they can do that and not
announce it until close to that time
they don't normally announce community
events until like literally we find out
on the day-ish that happens yes
increased like public event contact
blooms or
yeah who knows
i will say if if they're going to do
anything else gamble related which i
don't mind the moats
per se but between the dungeon and the
public event the delay in picking those
things up it's worse i think in the
dungeon
but like i kill a guy i'll watch the
moats come up and go down
and they're still not mine and then i
gotta run around and pick them up so i
just demotes themselves i would love
them to
fix the networking on those that's
always a little annoying shout out it's
witch queen cognito who made
made the name just for me oh yeah
seriously
is that your better half over there ah
clearly
incognito yes is it there's an emblem
for end of season event in collection
so there we go i didn't spot that one
yet didn't spot that either
good observation do 70 million contact
public events no
i don't know well i always wonder if
they're going to do anything with that
because it says a pyramid scale when the
ship arrives
i always wonder if there's like you know
the pyramid ships want something in
perfect balance
if they ever want us to work towards
something like that i don't know it'd be
a fun way to toy with the words but
it'll be funny
but that's kind of the only major
question mark stuff that we had
for increased redacted i mean you know
iron banner is going to be in there like
once every
three weeks probably it's going to be a
continuous thing
um and outside of that we know nightfall
grand master and everything's going to
it's getting a little bit of a change
for wards so higher chances at exotic
armor shards and stuff like that at the
tiers that platinum gold silva that you
finished grand master
i just think more people have a chance
to do it because
to get up to the level that you're going
for be it like 10 75 or something
wants you to grind for pin this is gonna
be the highest level i think people have
ever been
going into a future season because they
have so much time to grind for
even just like your plus one pinnacles
from your like strikes and crucible
matches and stuff
you got enough time you can still
probably get up to like max power level
oh yeah absolutely absolutely people
are gonna be very beefy at the end of
this season
before they get knocked back down titans
walker and be like dude i gotta go on a
diet
yep oh yeah people gonna be chunky
but yeah for the rest of this one it
actually started like really big be like
all right big delay festival losses come
in solstice of heroes we still don't
know as much about because it's still
about a month away so we'll get a little
bit as we go
um but outside of that there was
apparently a fix with like the
contender's shell
where people were like farming stuff so
they deactivated that and then some
patch notes but
overall the big news was the delay and
then kind of the adjustment to the
calendar
um so that's most of what happened this
week
yeah yeah it was pretty much i mean
that the big thing was yeah the you know
i'm getting in front of the announcement
you know um being transparent in that
respect so um
you know look they're adjusted they're
adjusting on the flies is a
a new new world new bungie and like i
said before i think it's one of those
things where
you know if they were under activision
they would not have been allowed
to to do this they would have been kind
of forced to be
on the assembly line and oh i've got i
never mentioned this i supposed to
mention this last podcast
did um and zoe did you guys catch uh
marty o'donnell making a recent
interview
uh i've seen pieces here and there yeah
yeah about his time and stuff like that
and how
he was like so happy eventually you can
tell he's a little better still
look a little better a little better but
salute the body
he's he's he's a legend but he's
definitely got a little
bitterness with some of the you know the
guy still left that bunch but
he did say that you know it was about
time that he's so happy that they were
separate because they did feel it was a
bad deal
when um they were with activision so um
it was just interesting it was it was
really interesting to see his
perspective
on things i just want to know if he had
caught that
zoe you seen that yet or uh no i didn't
see it but
i prefer them being on their own yeah
absolutely
absolutely and uh there are some rumors
also in reference to
um marketing and xbox
hearing that a lot no just putting yeah
putting some feelers out there a lot of
stuff i'm hearing remember again
ma it's not may never want to be along
the exclusive content around they're
done with that mostly yeah
but as far as marketing we're hearing
some rumblings so we'll see
you know obviously uh xbox has their big
event
um on 25th and they said no one knows
third
23rd excuse me yeah 2013. on xbox
so we have one of those 20s so um yeah
they're going to do the joint
and apparently know what you call it no
more
um services announcements strictly just
games right yep one
hour or so get ready yeah i'm excited i
want to see what they bring because
they've been
buying up studios had those working for
some time i'm curious where
i know some games take a while to build
so like some well it won't be all there
but i'm very excited to see what they
have to bring
yeah because hey xbox game pass i'll
still play them
oh yeah ultimate you're here now they've
added uh
gold you know xcloud in the service now
they made some more um
customer friendly moves so yeah going to
be interesting
i was gonna say have you seen the xbox's
uh it's like xbox pope
or somebody who does all the skills oh
that's my guy he's amazing
he made an iron lord podcast series x
oh he did oh that's beautiful it's like
golden
it is um i was like i want this for real
you're like however this has to get made
yes oh it's amazing he he's amazing i
think he did it
what's the latest one you saw that he
did oh god i've seen so many the
valhalla one was pretty cool because i
like the teal with like the darker color
there's there's so many there's some
really goofy ones too but i can't
remember all of them
but he's just got so many as like
they've been it's a it's a refrigerator
and but it's just a rectangle so it's
easy to design for so i like what yeah
but i've seen it like i think the same
guy or a couple like they did like the
miles morales like ps52 man dude like
all these skins that people create
why are they not selling these things
they should be like hiring these people
and just be like
special editions just everywhere it's
just like slap the two cosmetic panels
on it go
somebody's artists are fantastic
outstanding
so i wanted a destiny customer do it did
we ever get a destiny another destiny
console
it seems farther because they're less
exclusive so i don't know depends
i see less of it honestly because yeah
they were paired up with activision
activision with sony and that kind of
had that
they had the white ps4 and stuff like
that so i mean i remember those but i
think it's been to
been too long and i think they're more
universal to everybody to do a console
specific tie
would be interesting but for zoe i
wanted to ask you
um when it comes to like all the
different stuff we've done we've had
like the whispers the zero hours we've
had the dungeons had the raids
um kind of wanted to go through a couple
things for
one of them i can probably guess but
like your top three or four just like
exotic weapons or pieces of armor
that you enjoy using which they may
favor titans so i definitely want to
hear about this one
uh but i was just kind of curious your
favorite exotics in destiny because
i mean you live and breathe this game
and i don't know if you like have a
steady
loadout you use if you like to mix it up
just kind of curious your favorites on
exotics that you've got
um for titan it's definitely do matches
right now like
oh my god they're insane in pve and pvp
so for those who are un unknown about
the ways of a titan
uh what do they do and why are they so
good for you
well titans like punching and with do
matches when you punch stuff
it attaches to any other enemy that's
near it and kills them too
so if you two punch somebody in crucible
um like if there's even two or three
people stood near them they'll all die
um and if you punch one goblin at
garden boss you know the goblins that
spawn just in front of the boss if you
punch one they all die
wow that's brutal
but we don't need to tell anybody
actually because we don't want them to
get there okay
so what warlock and hunter exotics do
you like that we can nerf for them any
any favorites out there
um transversive for warlocks
i just like the reload function never
having to reload is amazing
okay it's nice yeah i love transverse
hunter i play least probably
video aspects okay
nice no it's warlock that's warlock arms
that's the one with snakes
i'm thinking of the wrong way i'm so bad
with names
uh the legs that make tether
give you all back oh
you're killing me here sorry
what an orpheus rig or if you're
straight yeah yes i don't begin with oh
feels bad no hunter love sorry chat we
got one warlock on two titans and here
we are uh
skewed not towards the hunters right now
my hunter is my lowest played by time by
far as well so
i'm you didn't say before this you'd ask
me questions about hunters
well i gotta keep you on your toes
that's part of the fun no no
no for quite a long time but um not
recently i
made it for like second half of destiny
one and
that's half of destiny mm-hmm
the white titan so why titan now why did
you switch that's so cool
i like to punch things
arts or anything for like real life
working out or stuff like that or is it
just like this is your way to take out
your aggression and you're like
i want to punch and i can do it
digitally um
no i don't do anything like that in real
life it's like doing our destiny
that's awesome i will say if i had to go
check my pvp stats
the amount of people i have punched
which probably is why i'm a titan
is probably skewed higher than i would
have guessed the average number of
people
if it was truly just punches now you
warlock shooting all your abilities out
of hand that doesn't count
i'm talking about real man up punches
i've got a feeling my like my stats are
probably higher than the average for
sure
at least i'm on the right class yeah i
mean i get it i get it you
feel overpowered that's the class today
[Laughter]
say overpowered yeah you know i'm
literally trying to solo the dungeon
right now and it's the hardest class to
do it on
i like how you use this uh antidotal
evidence and then that means everything
for titan's so hard yes continue
devour is honestly
pretty crazy no it's good it's good it
is
overpowered
i'm getting my receipts and continue
yeah
except when you try and jump thank you
thank you for that zoe i see we're here
now now we're here
dude you are so trained in the floof
game that should not be slowing you down
no just i am much better on warlock jump
since trying to use it the only thing is
if you get that momentum going down and
oh you're done nothing you can do to
bring it back there's nothing you can do
yeah you're done
i've like been going through the ribbons
and like falling off just for a second
and it's like
and i can come back if you're on that
downward trajectory on a war like you
may as well just wave up and be like see
ya yup
i'd be more impressed seeing somebody
survive a bad warlock jump than most
other things in the game
thank you thank you mm-hmm i tell people
the dissent fine ascent
it's like they made the normal jump on
hunter which is just like jumping
they made a super good jump on titan and
they were like just make a [ __ ]
version of that
exactly there well we gave him a crappy
jump so now we got to make him powerful
with well and self-reviving and all
these other things that they've had over
the years
so yeah you got to deal with your jump
because you can survive
the best of all of us well we just
stopped it we just got well of radiance
in two come
on now you guys have been you couldn't
choose you were the only class who could
revive yourself from
death before literally that's the way
people would so low rates before and be
like oh no i've died
i'm okay never mind i was that was
definitely broken but we would that
we're not going to act like satan 14
helmet
and weapons wasn't a fixture in those
raid groups
come on weapons of light who's got the
bubble yeah that was huge yeah everybody
wants to have the titan with you
but you're not putting up big damage
numbers you're like hey you stand in the
back so i can do more damage
that's what the titan's job was you stay
here
right that's literally how you clear red
you need the dps
yeah me i could revive myself in front
of a thousand times before the crow
there ain't gonna be nothing because it
slaps me
back in the brains over that bubble is
key we
we need that come on now what tights
don't
don't short changes controls over here
like guys guys
guys shout out to the tethers though
shout out to the golden guns
we like you yeah i mean when it comes to
pvp
like the highest school people i usually
watch hunters because
the dodge the wormhouse crown the
invisibility it's just it's terrifying
and you're on the other side of that i
am
and and the jump and true sight
start exposing some things hunters true
side hunters
yeah where's holly mod so he can carry
me to my seven trials when so i can get
my triumph
automatic war hack hunter i'm just
joking
have you done that already uh zoe the
trials wins or do you do trial do you do
trials that much i didn't even ask
um i've got unbroken and false title
um is there anything you're not good at
in this game the answer is no
actually i'm pretty sure it's just nope
good at everything i've played with
friends who are very good
gotta take all the credit for those um
also i'm gonna get the seven wins for
this triumph but i haven't got them yet
i haven't even tried it's like really
hard to want to go into trials
on pc yeah i think it's gonna be like
get if i can get a win on a card i'll
reset it and just be at the bottom of
the card until i can get my seven wins
i'm glad that's seven
people are gonna be doing that oh i know
it's hopefully it's just a decent amount
of rng i need to do it soon before the
people like
start falling out of that pool though
have you ever
jumped into trial no i have nothing
we got flawless title last season and
they didn't even change the name of it
what reason have we got to go into
trials this season at all same gear same
title
yeah well that's the same thing yeah
good point they said they would need
more time to uh to get that stuff
rolling
yeah well season 13
weapons again like i want them i want
the weapons to be overpowered for pve
so that people have to go play trials
for
the best pve weapons and then i want the
best some of the best pvp weapons not
all of them obviously
like there to be multiple places to get
but like in in general i want like a
really good pvp weapon in a raid so then
that pvp people
raids it's just i like it when the
community walks like that yeah
yeah absolutely i agree i agree i like
that a lot we had it for a while we're
those are the best games those are the
best guns in the whole game they didn't
do it the other way around though right
there's no
like super overpowered raid weapon
that's good i
really want them to do that i want them
to bring back raid perks
and i'm hoping with like whether it be
sunsetting or anything else that we get
some
ultra powerful raid weapons again
because we've been i think that's one of
the reasons because you mean
every raid that we when we started
talking about those earlier you've got
wrath of the machine you've got vog and
you have weapons that were like
oh i can't fatebringer you had a vision
of confluence you had vex mythic class
which was just busted for a minute
but you also had like the double perks
later and we've always talked like the
rewards
i'm hoping they fixed that in the fall
for raids because the rewards in d2 have
been
weak on the raids they don't stand out i
agree i got a question for you though
and zoey too like do you guys obviously
we all talk fondly
about weapons and raids in d1
legendary right we'll agree that there's
some exotics weapons
oh dude yeah they're great sick right
shout out 1k voices shout out to energy
but my question do you think i was just
thinking about it right now
the fact that random roles are
in the raids legendaries may have
something to do with the
the lack of specialty because if you
play a raid and then it's like okay you
get a
kind of terrible like for example i did
prophecy right
and what's the new supposedly
i got horrible rolls i got two runs
horrible rolls on it do you think that
plays a part into it maybe
not that we gotta have like curated or
stuff like that as
everyone getting the same thing but i
don't know
what you guys think i kind of like it i
like the fact that it makes it more
replayable because then you want to go
back next week to get the better roll
it kind of brings back that feeling when
guns were more rare drops in d1
like you do bought a glass and there'd
be people waiting weeks and weeks to get
a found verdict or weeks and weeks to
get the
of the class and that's what gets you
excited when you finally get it it's
like yay
right we need that excitement i think
it's a balance of both
because if you wait as you said it was
like i was trying to get fatebringer it
took me like
months probably or not months because at
some point we got to credit but it took
me like
repetitive weeks to ever just to see it
drop that's the only one you ever need
when you get it to drop
now on the other side for zoe issues run
a raids constantly get a new drop every
week
that's cool as well somewhere in between
i would like the raid drops to be
a step above like better combinations of
perks add an additional perk like
yeah find some way to make the raid gear
[Music]
like stand out from if i go do a strike
and i get a legendary drop and i go do a
raid
those should not be on the same level i
need like three perks
maybe like i'm with you slightly
different scopes with like hey you get
extra zoom a little extra re-handling
the best reload speed and like stuff
that isn't gonna break it's where it's
like
hey this 600 auto rifle hits for one
thousand damage every bullet like
nothing like to that level but like you
know a reload speed perk that's going to
be the fastest because hey that's going
to be a little bit
better aim assist and then maybe maybe
you can get dynamic sway reduction
zen moment and kill clip or some like
combinations where you make those
because they got to stand out because
that's yeah like the random roles are
fine and there are some good ones but if
you know outlaw kill clip and i'll kill
clip they're about the same that doesn't
do me as much
incentive to get back in there so my
hope is for
a step above both for trials and raids
yeah you're nailing it that's what i
think it is i think it's
i think they need to i'm going to join
with they can keep the random i think
they
have to though increase the chances of
curated
uh just a little bit you know saying i
also feel like you said the number one
thing though
is they have to like add perk
combinations that are unique that
normally wouldn't happen
you know what i'm saying like just so
that you have more chances of it also
what i like that the season pass does
is that you got that extra perk
you know when you you get through the
season pass and then you get to that
third level yes so now even if it's not
the i
do you got the hope of something you can
switch to you know what i mean
i i love like now we'll be getting the
iklos weapons
i'm getting shout out to that shotgun
what does it last in last out or
whatever it is
i know yeah i love that all bro that
slug is nice
that slug is arc it's nice it hits like
a truck
those pve slugs got buffed like 30
percent and like
i've got vorpal on it and and i've got
what else i like auto loading or
something like that
it's really beast and pve but i love the
fact that you get that
extra perk slot and i would love that or
something like that for raids it would
be really
really cool just to add a little flavor
make them a little more special
yeah i think that's where i think that
would be what would set them apart
yes i agree
well i'm trying to think of it i was
like i was trying to ask you oh
um i know we got the one moment about
you carrying
the the couple to their platinum which
that's an awesome story especially when
you said they screamed at the end that's
beautiful uh we
we try and ask our guests like top three
moments just in the history of destiny
i'm sure that's one somewhere in there
but what are two other like just
favorite moments whether it's been
you know a certain clear anything like
that just top other two moments for you
just in your history of destiny
um i don't know it's hard to think of
like specific moments
the friends i've made along the way is
my favorite thing
that's awesome
trying to think
i've enjoyed my day one attempt raids
but some of them have been really
stressful so
how long do you how long do you stick in
those day ones are you in them for like
the 24 hours or yeah i won't leave
i'm not leaving what's the longest
you've gone
trying to beat one of those or do you
give up at 24.
um usually stop at 24 but i'll have been
awake before that as well so it's like
usually about 30 hours
you can't go to sleep straight after
either because like
likes a little bit wind down that's not
the longest
um i've streamed though during corridors
i did
[Music]
40 hours how ruined were you on sleep
when you were how close together were
those two
i had a 12 hour sleep between them i
literally went to sleep woke up started
again
wow so okay 40 hours 12 sleeping 40
hours
do you sleep for like 24 after that or
um
no i slept for like about five hours and
then got back up because it was about to
get finished and i didn't want to miss
it finish it oh my god
so i did about 10 hours it was over 90
hours that week
10 hours that time and then i went to
sleep for about 15 hours after that
jeez wow
yeah that that's that's awkward how do
you
went and got got in bed and went to
sleep and i was still there i was like
i'm going longer than you
so what is the secret to like those
because i mean some people do like you
know
24 hour streams 28 40 is a new number
because that's awesome
um how do you manage how do you manage
that long of a stream like what is the
secret to
long-term streaming because the average
will do like four or five six hours
call it food over energy drinks don't
use energy drinks at the start you can
use them i go
generally go for sugar-free ones because
you don't want a sugar crash
if you have the super sweet energy
drinks you can have a sugar crash and
feel twice as tight as
anyway yeah um it was a super
low energy kind of thing corridor so it
was just taking screenshots and
transcribing them into a spreadsheet so
it wasn't like i was having to super
concentrate
that'd be a lot harder to do if you were
like literally
i was going to say would that almost
like lull you do you almost ever fall
asleep on stream at any point if you
were just like waiting on your next
screenshot just like click
uh i was like getting to the point where
i could barely talk but not actually
wow i don't know i'm really weird when
it comes to like if i'm
like i wouldn't even go to sleep
straight after i'd usually need like a
bit of time to
wind down oh that's it that's hardcore
shout out to your chitty chat
all right they a lot of people say hey
that's how they found you a lot of
people say that in the chat right now
right don't worry about that actually
reminded me of one of my favorite
moments i helped
um jazz and his friends five people who
had never done crown the first week when
it came out i'd only done it twice
myself and i helped them get there clear
nice that was one of my favorite things
i've done was that like
the jazz that guy yeah yeah he put he
put out a video a
recording of it and all the funny parts
and stuff nice
he i didn't know he was going to do this
but he actually like put my twitch at
the start of it and
underneath i got like 3k follows in a
week wow
that's fantastic that's awesome that's
awesome and that's kind of
the moments yeah i was gonna say that's
kind of the final thing i wanted to
bring up for you
you like from the questions we asked you
before you mentioned it multiple times
and
obviously stuff like that just the we we
talk about the community sometimes as
well it's just like
a unique piece to this whole game that
we're in
and it sounds like that's the like
that's the biggest piece for you so it's
like have there been
any like community moments for you with
yours any crazy things that have gone
off
like i've seen people get like crazy sub
trains or
as you said 3 000 followers from a video
like any big
big big community moments that just make
you i mean you're already like locked
into the community but there's just like
cemented be like this is like my
favorite place to be
do that all the time i don't really
think that's anything to do like i've
had some crazy sub moments but i
wouldn't say they made me feel more part
of the community
when that that time i was just saying
about when glad fell asleep his
community came over to my chat and we
went on over a 500 sub train
that was insane and made me cry and
stuff but like the community makes me
feel part of it just by being my friend
not really by giving me anything
that's awesome like awesome yeah it's
the
i mean cognito and i literally met
because of this game because we're crazy
and we went to guardian con and stuff
and it's
it's all better friends through this
game than i've ever met in real life
where i used to i've recently moved so
i'm much happier where i am now but
where i used to live i didn't feel like
anybody where i lived thought the same
as me it was a very
different type of area and i felt like i
finally found people who
like who think the same and who i can
get on with like my community is not
just people who
watch my stream they're also people who
could call me at two o'clock in the
morning if they were having a problem oh
my actual friends
that's awesome yeah yeah and that that's
the thing about destiny which makes it
so special
you know it's just it's just one of
those things that you can't
discount this community the friendships
that are made
you know the connections you meet people
and
it's just something about this game it
just it had that's the
that's that hook you know it it is the
friend game
on a lot of levels it true it truly is
it's just the cooperative stuff
challenging stuff and just
you know being able to take those
friendships on and and grow them
from outside of destiny as well and then
meeting those people in real life and
getting to hang out with them too i've
been to the last three guardian cons and
they were all
amazing oh you were the one last year 20
oh man yeah we were there like man uh
what is
yeah so there was a huge party the day
before guardians started
ghanaian started at a pub that everybody
went to like
glad and all that were there me and
tamzin and all that were there that was
my birthday party
oh wow wow that's awesome i think i
ended that night i think i ended up
going to
what's that karaoke bar yeah we went to
a karaoke bar i'm going to say
fall out and fall out you know and yeah
there were some out there for sure
yeah we missed the birthday party invite
but now we're gonna have to we give you
a happy birthday
i went up to chevy and i said um
i said to him oh all you were drinking
shots without me
um about an hour later i had to put
myself in an uber
in fairness i saw glad probably a few
too many shots in as well at one of the
nights oh yeah oh yeah we saw that
yeah after my birthday was the night he
wet himself
just him sleeping it looked like
ridiculously cozy and like some like red
pajamas or something i think or
something
[Music]
shout out to glad dude we gotta get him
on here at some point
he is amazing he's just a normal nice
guy honestly
and he can party harder than most people
yes
yeah that keto diet's paying off well
because that man can
apparently drink with the best of them
so yeah i absolutely
learn more every day
now guardian con though i think that's i
haven't gone to like
because i mean cocktail's been to like
e3s and stuff like that so he said those
guardian khan's like my first real
like coming together over one thing
convention major that i've really ever
done i did it in 20
was it 16 when i met you and then 19 was
the big one at rosen shingle creek
yeah when if hopefully cross our fingers
we get our act together over here
next year hopefully when we get to do
that especially doing the podcast having
awesome people like you i cannot
wait i'm gonna go broke buying people
drinks or just honestly shaking hands
and saying hopefully we can shake hands
but
yeah like seriously so many amazing
people in this community that
i'm good i'm gonna spend two days just
saying hello and talking to people just
to say hey
i can't and that's that's so amazing for
people that we meet online and we're so
excited to just do that
absolutely it's like something you never
experience anywhere else because you're
never going to have that many friends in
one place at the same time
it's like i literally feel like i've got
200 friends in one place and we all go
partying together it's crazy
mm-hmm yeah it's it's awesome it's like
a you know it's like a fraternity it
just
it's so cool and then um you know like
now like with like what he said it's
just like doing you know doing the last
word
you know getting a little bit of of
growth and stuff like that and now
you know having you know you guys on now
putting the face to the name and that
like
the connection now now and then you meet
them in real life you're like okay
and i think that was what i was looking
forward to the most
this year because a lot of people
because i'm being like i'm still
fairly like he knows more than me you
know as far as people in the community
you know i mean i'm still getting
ingratiated with life you meet people
you don't know online already too that's
what's really funny
so i actually met two of my closest
friends now at the first guardian cut i
went to and i didn't know them online
before that
so i met them in real life at the
convention and then now i've been
friends
online for years awesome yeah this guy
and i handed each other business cards
three years later we're still doing a
crazy podcast so
2016. that's literally how it went down
literally
the birth were you at that guardian con
the one with the tournament
yes oh yeah yeah that's i was that's the
first one i went to
yep yep 2016. i missed 17 and 18 then we
did 19.
as the return 2016. i want 2017
solo and then cause 2017 that's when i
met um
caccus that's not mechanics for the
first time and then um
2019 yeah 2018 i skipped with you as
well and then 2019 we went
yeah so i can't wait to get back it's
gonna be so much fun
i mean that's kind of as you said it's
like i i've always been one of those
people who have a very very small group
of friends like i'll hang out with like
one or two people or i have like two
couples that we hang out with and stuff
like that
and that's kind of what you describe now
it's like when we go back yeah it's like
200
like people that i know and even more
like awesome people meeting the bungee
devs was awesome meeting
oh yeah like talking with them for a
little bit and just like so many people
you meet and it's like
everybody i don't i think everybody was
like the nicest people i've ever met in
the entire convention it's like such
a positive and awesome place and
i don't know i can't i was it was a
bummer to be missed but i think next
year is going to be so much more special
it could be like three days and it's not
gonna be long enough next year it's
gonna be crazy
it's going to be we usually go for like
at least a whole week because we see
people before and after the event to do
other things like go theme parks or go
shopping just hang out
yeah we did orlando my wife and i did
the harry potter stuff at orlando for
one of the days and another we just like
sat her in the pool but now i'm gonna be
like
gonna be dragging my wife to meet all
these people like who are all these
people i don't know them and be like
you're coming too
[Laughter]
awesome couple of j speak some people
ask me
my wife actually had the oh go ahead no
she had a great time right she had a
great time because she was
it's hilarious it's like the i don't
know what it says about me but honestly
it's a weird story because every time i
tell this i'm always like it doesn't
make me come off in the best light like
i love my wife we have like a great
relationship we do but it's like between
her with like work and the dogs and just
like
whether you know we're we're both cancer
so we can never decide anything anyway
but
um it was me at the convention for like
two days and she was just like
she wasn't at home no dogs no work no
nothing and she was just like she woke
up
got a nice little breakfast i'd have
breakfast with her and then she'd be bee
but i pulled by the pool
go order a couple drinks go have some
sushi she felt like
so relaxed she's like it was one of the
best like vacations she's ever had
because she had to care literally about
nothing and including me which is always
the bad joke
but it's just like she had she enjoyed
just like this just
to the chill place at rose and shingle
creek out there
and then i'd like try and grab her for
dinner and stuff like that because she's
not into it and everything but yeah it's
like
if i could ever get her into it but i
don't think i could ever get turned her
into a gamer at this point in her life
i think you have to explain like the
hotel though why it would have been so
good because it was it's not just a
normal
average hotel it's a [ __ ] mansion
with a company
zoe i call it the leviathan or vote
[ __ ] and then it goes underneath and
earth as well like this
we didn't even see half of it there was
a hold of a side that we were in
it was like the tennocon and there were
two other like conventions we weren't
even part of the conventions going on
like this [ __ ]
like you literally do not have to leave
this
estate like it is humongous for anyone
in the chat who is not going to gcx
rosen shingle creek is the leviathan
of hotels like the you it's the
all-inclusive
everything they have a golf course on
this thing is
alligators god in it yeah there's a boat
yeah there's a moat there's like there's
a steak house down the walkway you got
like the sushi bar some amazing burgers
by the way i know that's like oh yeah
those were solid burgers the bar was
right there mexican restaurant
all laid like eat alley at the
convention down there the buffet
like multiple pools i mean that was
outside seating areas with rocking
chairs yes
did you stay at the hotel or were you
like did you do like an airbnb
or something i went across the road okay
we were literally but it was so hot
during the day we'd get a taxi over from
across the road because there was that
big driver walking up there you'd be
sweating
by the time you got a long drive yeah
that's not even remotely close to a road
i'd walk home on a night because it was
literally not even a 10 minute walk
but during that it was too hot during
the day to walk we'd get taxis during
the day and walk on a night it was funny
oh when my wife and i were in orlando we
made it to about noon or one o'clock and
we had seen the two harry potter
sections of the park we both kind of
looked at each other everything you done
yeah there's a swamp going on in all my
clothes right now so we gotta get out of
here yeah
yeah it's so weird being in florida for
like for me as an english person it's
very strange that you go inside to get
cold and outside to get water
yes yes that's not the way it is here
if you guys don't have you don't have
air conditioner typically most of you
don't right
no no we don't have air conditioner at
all like maybe some stores
like have a big fan on your way in or
something but that's about it really
no like i said i told the chef i mean
guys
if you're a destiny fan it is
one of the most fun experiences and then
the cool part about it is just the rent
it's so big the randomness like
you could be going from one location oh
there's that oh there's deej there
like you're literally seeing everyone
and it's just huge and everybody's
destined out
it it's just so much fun like i i i
cannot subscribe
to you you can talk to all all the
people who stream who you think
this person or that person you walk up
to them and have a normal conversation
normal conversations normal people
every all your street favorite streamers
are literally just normal people
they'll have a drink for the year
they'll hang out yes the coolest thing
like shout out to member um
pino we were talking to piano from um
you know
bungie you know the the natural
conversation the big show comes by
the voice he's huge
i know you're talking that six eight
tall but all right
you know that might be there but um
let's you know it's just
so cool and you know like one of the one
of the coolest things i ever
i have my like gopro camera and
in in the course of about 20 minutes of
just
walking around with this thing i
literally bump into like some of my
favorite content creator
but oh there's bife oh there's fallout
there you know like
it's jus it's just non-stop and then the
cosplays and the
like it doesn't get more fun than this
it's one of the best i'll actually put
the link shut up with the lightning just
to give you guys
a feel a small little i even meet e i
meet up with e
on this thing because he was late but
that's what that was
i was late it was that crazy i was
trying to check in or something
was like yeah like a bad jacket or
something well i got there
like the day before it started but i
didn't get to the out
the resort before like pre-check-in
so i had to like wait in the check-in
line turn back around go wait in the big
yeah it was later so
yeah it's so much fun and like i said
you
as a destiny fan you owe it to yourself
to at least go to one gcx
what you have to go to one if you follow
people in the community if you've been
playing the game you got friends that go
worth every penny it's so good and the
resort even if you like hey the
convention's kind of over
go hang out in the pool go eat at the
cool restaurants go hang out in the bar
like
it's just amazing resort vacation anyway
and then awesome destiny people too it's
like
just everything perfectly combined chat
i put a uh
that gopro video i was talking about
ease on there i'm on there a couple of
fun people
on there check it out if you get a
chance just if again if you guys have
never been
it's something that's really fun it's
really cool shout out to italian shout
out to bromance
shout out to lupo all i mean everybody
who's responsible saint jude
it's just it's gamers and destiny
paradise
yeah on the hotel leviathan so check
that out
well that's about all i got i know we're
wrapping up right here at two hours so i
want to respect zoe's time because she's
got a stream that's gonna wait on her
because
she's got backpack space and she's got
to get people in there so
uh zoe i just wanted to give you a
chance first to say thank you very much
for coming on it was an absolute blast
having you here this morning
and um i just wanted to give you a
chance to kind of
say your outro where people can find you
what you'll be doing
obviously writing for the next three
months but what you got coming up
pretty much lots of raid helps um i've
soloed prophecy but i haven't solo
flawlessed it yet so i've got a lot to
do
nice nice um wait till the raid helps
die down a little bit
um find me on twitch at zoe underscore
twitter on zoey
tv nice
well um cognito
yeah man well first of all again salute
is over coming through
love to hear the stories love to hear
from salute to her gaming prowess
seriously man that's so good
i love to hear the flex like i like how
she's like you know i just stay quiet
and just just just knock out do
everything just have them in
awe you know i love hearing stuff like
that it's salute it's always good to
have
you know you on the platform and stuff
like that telling your stories
and stuff like that so salute to you for
coming to really appreciate you know you
spending your time with us had a lot of
fun
um yeah you already know me at cognito
on twitter you already know every sunday
is the lord's day
1 p.m eastern youtube twitch check us
out man we're going to be doing
um xbox showcase game showcase
prediction
panel so we have a next week is the
follow up
yeah we do the prediction and then we do
the aftermath yeah we gotta
do a prediction then we do a live
reaction and then we do it after that so
it's a busy
busy week of um of gaming so we'll talk
about that um big panel will most likely
have
ainsley bowden from season gaming huge
huge gamers guys big in the community
knows his stuff super knowledgeable
passionate
um we'll also have tim dawg resident
xbox aficionado
and one of the up and comers and
separate ghost he's a he's a big xbox
guy as well
so we got to do like a little xbox
problem we do these little pre-show
things
unfortunately there's no e3 because
normally we'd have like a playstation
show
an xbox show and a switch show but no e3
so you just gotta kind of scatter it
around so check this out sunday 1 p.m
eastern law cockney on twitter
lords of gaming.net salute man please i
appreciate all the support
for the riders it really means a lot to
us and uh getting the content out to you
guys and you guys clicking on the
articles in the website and um
you know that last word you know you
gotta you gotta be here for that
that campfire talk with e doing intros
now what
whoa i gotta try and live up to the
reputation of cognito's intros
that was the first one well never awful
rough but i got like i'll work on it
i'll see but
i gotta take the pressure off this man
he he sets a pretty high standard for
intro so
we gotta make sure it's uh done properly
uh but before we go guys make sure you
guys hang out once we wrap up the
podcast i want to go raid ob katie cat
she is working hard this morning she's
streaming so
i want to send the love over there to
her um so definitely hang out in chat
i'll see you guys over there so you can
blow up her
chat but yeah um thank you very much zoe
thank you for one for getting me through
spire because that was fantastic too
please continue to flex on people and
occasionally try and just like
not finish a raid or an encounter just
so you can flex on the damage numbers
too
drop some screenshots up there just so
we could
you'd be like oh no we failed the
encounter i have all the damage
so weird i've definitely never thought
that while i was doing
oh you still have to do that please do
that at some point
like somebody's talking smack you just
go in there and be like well i got like
90
of the damage were you at that would be
so beautiful
um but yeah so thank you very much and
then zoe like when we wrap up we was
trying to say the last word together
don't wait on me as soon as i give this
little pause
it's going to be up to you so well thank
you guys for hanging out it's been
episode
112 july 17th this has been amazing zoe
thank you for coming
and for this episode it has been
the last word